welcome Batman I'm mark Barnard and I'm
Kevin Smith today on our show we've got
Chris Daughtry the sequel the
christening
Batman old Batman
let me tell you this man you're doing it
right dude
because like you're doing your main
thing the thing that got you there
anything you're passionate about but you
don't stop there some people just stop
there some people are like I'm just
gonna focus obsessively on that got to
put my eggs and oh it in baskets all of
them do all of them in this lifetime and
think about I think what you're doing
right now with like I want to draw on I
want to act and we'll do this I'm gonna
do all these things you need to refill
your attitude like you didn't
ambidextrous totally you got here on the
fuel that fed you all the way through
childhood through teenagers until you
picked up the guitar then that took you
where he needs to go but now it's not
like you're I'm running on fumes or
something but you've got a refill and
how you refill is the same way you
filled the first time yeah like you're
living life so there's all that other
data coming in but like I think every
artists it's not reversion you sometimes
go back to the source you go back to the
beginning to chart a course or just be
like oh yeah sometimes it's this simple
you love that [ __ ] then you just got
real [ __ ] monumentally busy and this
is the first moment you've had in a
decade to be like what was that doing
before oh yes yeah that's happened to me
many times where I'm like oh let me pick
this up again and ten years you hear it
already and you're like that's that's
what I do know is how does it feel
though like that's being a Renaissance
man woman whatever how does it feel
spinning a bunch of plates I mean I'm
glad that that we're not able to know
the future because if somebody someone
told me when I was five years old oh
yeah you're gonna be an artist when
you're 36 I would have been like now I'm
good
so yeah I mean I think it's I think it's
great that my attention was completely
taken off of actually even comic books
in general for years because I kind of
had I mean I got to make money out of
family I got a work they had to do real
[ __ ] and it got to a point where I was
like bills paid what do I want to do and
picked up a pencil but I didn't I mean I
guess at the time I did that I wasn't
thinking I'm gonna pursue that I'm just
thinking this is fun yeah yeah I got a
career I'm not gonna be chasing that too
and it just kind of happened
I mean passion is a caveman passion is a
key that unlocks just about every door
like it was a thing that I loved the
thing that I want to do more than
anything will find a way to get there it
could take 20 years oh my kids all the
time whatever you love doing like fun
find a way that that is gonna make you
money yes and you'll never have a job
like you will always love doing what
you're doing because it's that's what
you were made to do you'll earn by that
thing that you've got anyway but it's
it's work I mean it's not like oh yeah
that's gonna happen when things come
around you have to like go find ya kick
down doors and see who let you in mm you
know yeah like make those embarrassing
emails to people sometimes
certainly what did you ever now if
you're a musician and you are do you
ever go like oh I could score things as
well like if you ever thought about
scoring movies it's interesting because
I feel like as a musician mmm like as
someone who sits down and picks up any
instrument and just composes I think
that's a like I'm more of a melody guy
and then I'll find the chords to go
around it but there's way more like
interesting like Trent Reznor I mean
that guy's he's a genius
hmm but that guy also plays like he
knows exactly what do you I can play I
don't know what I don't know how to tell
you play when I'm playing right you can
do this just kind of how I grew up my
dad plays by ear and I just kind of
learned some chords and went from there
but yeah I've been kind of approached
with would you be interested in doing
something like that
maybe a commercial small you like it
took me [ __ ] six weeks to draw the
pencils take me two minutes short yeah
I'm one of those guys that I can pick up
anything not saying I'm I can do it as
fast as is the professional can but I
will find my way whether through Google
or the mirror or whatever I'm always
using every resource I can to make it
happen but yeah I just I'm glad that
I've at least got this cover done and
hopefully hopefully the fans love it and
I don't know it it's kind of surreal
still to be honest the after this and
not after tonight but after doing the
cover do you think there's like a place
where you wind up in the regular
rotation they reach out to you and be
like hey do you want do the old cover
that's happening become a cover guy for
them even if you're like I haven't
earned that that would be the extent of
what I
would want to do in comics I would love
to do covers because that's a one and
done type situation and it's the glories
the sport is amazing and I love how
Coppola does this covers where they're
so simple but from a distance it's this
iconic image so it's not a lot of
rendering and which was interesting
considering how much he didn't spawn and
how simplified he made his style yet
it's still very him you know what I mean
but the way he does panels and and it's
like a he's done a lot of studying much
like I've done with songwriting up to
this point he's done that work in that
and I don't see myself getting to a
point where I'm like alright give me a
book ten thousand hours man a while you
like it there any Jim's assistant would
be texting me going how far you I'm just
got that layout done on that first page
it's solid
can you get anybody else to cover them
next twenty some pages when is the live
thing just [ __ ] so wins so we got we
had the greatest hits album come out two
weeks ago okay then we it's just called
dr. grace called it's not over still
doing this that or this is the best [ __ ]
we could write or songs you've already
bought so that's out Nega that remove
singles torches that's out blast it
radio now and then the passion is March
20th then the clubhouse it's on Fox at 8
it's prime time hey Judas
I'm Judas Iscariot you take the take the
Jews story oh that's so brother
warehouse dude it's it's the rehearsals
were pretty intense
really yeah how long is he I think it's
two hours I haven't seen the rest of it
because I only went there to rehearse my
scenes and came back a seals in it
simply he's pilot really that's God
baddest he's if he's British yeah and
the Romans I can't wait I don't think
he's ever acted before I mean these kiss
from a rose but that's pretty much he
must see my songs
because he is an act like it's okay
performance that you would have to plug
in like yes like he's so visually
compelling now like you he's like
intense looking you got a stare at him I
can't wait to see what he does but so
that and then the 23rd Batman number 50
that drops and it's digital and I'll be
doing a signing at we're at Golden Apple
oh really
on the 24 kids go to the day before
Batman vs Superman comes out Wow an
apple they have the great Alisa comic
book stores in the world that's here in
Los Angeles it's right on Melrose used
to be deeper on Melrose yeah it's a
fantastic fantastic comic book store so
come on lots of legend legged legacy
beyond it
what day are you there the 24th I think
at 5 p.m. and who's just you sign myself
I'm not sure if Jim's coming or not I
think he was trying to figure out his
schedule but I will definitely come when
the comments go out Friday
it's a Saturday today would they ask me
the comics teens Wednesday when is it
Wednesday no yeah so the music is Friday
sorry Tuesday used to be Tuesday and now
the music is Friday but the movies are
still Tuesday yeah movies movie theater
for all the same day okay so the 24th
I'll be doing that and then of course if
they were like I'm Andy she's a very
[ __ ] next day if they were like hey at
the signing will you play as a little
song would you keep those six separate
you're like yeah problem I mean if he
asked me I'm people but now everybody's
gonna
got replay we assume I'm in the car who
he like I'm just here to fire I would
just do this well technically is playing
a song yeah thanks a lot
signing your first signing for commerce
you ever sign on like albums and I
signed at the art gallery with Jim for
the we can be heroes things so that was
kind of cool because usually the
signings are there Daughtry fans and I'm
in a whole new pool
Jim Lee and his his people and that dude
takes forever to sign as he takes like
at least five minutes per person which
is outstanding to be honest it was very
inspiring to watch I was like man you
step up my game
thank you talk my gaming at that right
head work
yeah he's a good talkative man he's very
like he's personal he's everybody
freaking smart man guys but but this
will be my first comic sign so that's
that's that's one person man what a
Comic Cons like for you like when you go
down there is it batshit crazy is it
it's it seems like increasingly so
lately because I think they're aware
that I would be there where before it
was like he wouldn't be here I hear he
likes this yeah now they're like looking
for me before I'm the first time I went
I had a Batman cow alone yeah I made the
one one or whatever
everybody wanted pictures I was like no
thanks
turns out and nobody gives a [ __ ] about
Chris Daughtry nobody wanted pictures
what a dick
exactly what I wanted to do but yeah I
need to branch out though and go to more
cons because I've only been to San Diego
he's San Diego's what's your family I
mean San Diego probably is the but
outside WonderCon DragonCon one of the
more amazing it would particularly when
I was in San Francisco but it's moving
so late and I'm was LA this year really
yeah what time said I'm really mmm that
was always bitching like very very from
the show is it yeah right around this
time about maybe super help I'm gonna be
up there doing flash I like that yeah I
love Chicago that is so awesome you're
directing how good is that show that
show is [ __ ] phenomenal they do it's
a nice comic book show that's ever had
GV I think he's right and I'm and I
ain't taking anything away from Darren
old people like [ __ ] you Daredevils
amazing daredevil is amazing but
daredevil is kind of this work of art
that transcends comic-book it looks like
a graphic novel comes to life flashes
flash really really panel like say it's
a I'm a single principle it's the pages
on screen yes [ __ ] normally [ __ ] it's
the pages on screen total in three shots
every and he'll shown is a [ __ ] how
issue come to life mom yeah so I'm going
up there do one of those grass sounds
like your father's crazy flash picture I
said Iman and I didn't realize at the
time he's from North Carolina he
literally went really I thought I was
Canadian
he went no he's from Virginia really he
went to Elon College when I had just
moved back to North Carolina and lived
in Burlington North Carolina and played
at the club outside of Elon College he
was going to school there and then he
was from Virginia which I used to live
in Virginia crazy parallels and then he
lived in Charlotte when I lived there or
or I'm sorry like a few years before I
was paying you this kid moves fast
Nathan
yeah I look forward to it man but here
on TV if there's open rolls I was gonna
be like [ __ ] man thanks for bringing up
Daughtry but you're gonna be [ __ ]
playing me you're gonna be condemning
jazz I've been talking to Jeff I've been
talking to you Jeff about roles and such
give us a two shot over here give the
boy jabs you come on he wants to act and
he's done singing he's not done he's no
he just wants to act as well he wants to
expand his portfolio
I like the Underwood three four jobs all
right but yes that shows is definitely
doing it but I guess it it knows what it
does out the gate though oh yeah they
had those two years of arrow under the
belt like hey listen we're not gonna
[ __ ] waste time yeah go now how do
you feel about legends man Oh louder
than Brandon Ralph because he's the
scene stealer he's wonderful
I love the legends I think they're doing
it right I hope it continues I hope I
like that it exists flash for me is
still like it that's the one you know
[ __ ] because that show has to like it's
not like they got too many characters
but there's a lot of storylines to
balance where as flash you do have much
characters but it's his what it all
makes its old and it's following his
journey it's like the story of a you
know boy who loses his parents at a
young age even though his dad's still
alive and then putting his life together
and each house season one technically
should have ended it because he's like
alright I know who killed Bob but then
it led to season two so it's his journey
and it's easy to like anything it's easy
to focus on one character and
emotionally invest in that character
yeah with all but the legends of
tomorrow they're great characters
they're well [ __ ] drawn they're well
acted but they don't get to spend the
amount of time yet they'll spend with
Barry yeah and and it doesn't have the
same emotional center oh it's fun it's
like while whiz-bang
but like I said like they're not doing
anything wrong this is not like they
need advice but give it time like you
know once they establish this is what
our show does the whiz-bang our weeding
out the I think they'll start like
laying some more on stern weak links
they'll just be like this episode will
focus on these two and lifts over here
and stuff but I dig it man it's like
think [ __ ] every week they're doing
an action yeah I mean flash does that
too and I guess arrows well I don't
watch her but like whenever you watch
flash like Jesus Christ that's like yeah
shows that I make sure that I watch that
night and that's Walking Dead mmm me too
arrow and the flash but sometimes I got
mister freeze now though and I got Hugo
Strange Monday you're Batman like and
we're not this has not come down no I
love God we be supportive come with you
why are we watch as there's there's
parts of it that I love
I think Robert Lord Taylor is affection
is excellent I think Ben McKenzie is
excellent there's a lot of over-the-top
acting going on a lot of weird writing
and some she's not on the show anymore
she's not on the show
no but there's somebody the background
stuff seems over-the-top and and almost
forever like Batman from really in a
kind of arch it has that this is a comic
book-y a show where the other ones feel
a little more like they know what it
what they are and they're drinking it
earnestly and yes flash looks like
unapologetically lucky comic book show
but the tone is unified Kotok whereas
Gotham there's no [ __ ] gritty Plus
weirdly operatic over here and like
crazy cartoonish over there and those
things just don't mean there's elements
that I love about it that that kept me
watching on the first season I want it
to be on forever
I will get around I love you I would
love to see Bruce Wayne skip a few years
and and let's show some real life that
he went through yeah but I don't think
that this worries would be fully fleshed
out right now no and I think you're
right I think it's like the more that I
know Sam well we know I'm not getting a
job
get your [ __ ] hired you out they're
gonna tell you what to do no no I first
of all I had never thought in a million
years that I'd be seeing one out of two
billboards having a superhero and I can
and it's plan next week it's two out of
two billboards everywhere then Deadpool
I mean who knew except for those guys
here's this is the beauty of where my
friends live out in advance because that
one at that screening uh so I was like
no way this won't do big this is the
most dressed up character in comic-con
every year that's a good time to be
alive but but it's where so much is a
volume of stuff out there that we can be
Precious about [ __ ] like Gotham you know
what I'm saying like any other ten years
ago if they gave us 15 years ago if you
got a superhero movie you were like whoa
can't wait for mm whatever or 1999 is
the best public school everywhere and
that's why we get to be like like I
don't say well you were allowed to but
that's why I get well of course we're
laughter we're consumers we can go up
where you go down but like they get kind
of like wow get around to there like I
remember when they first announced that
sure I was like oh my god I'm a [ __ ]
step on my kids neck to watch it and
it's like I will watch it when the
season is done so I can kind of go
through everything so but that's I think
just because there's so much material
which means the fingers step up to the
plate with one of these you got to bring
something nobody you know Nick Swardson
tsk yeah yeah this bet was talking about
like yeah this buddy's where you go see
a movie and you're like that sucked
mmm suck you guys went to see
transformers yeah saw it sucked
it's like if you imagine like 50 years
ago being shown that movies like it's so
much of it they were like trying to
explain the children what it was like to
see Jurassic Park for the first time
[ __ ] there were dinosaurs real
[ __ ] dinosaurs like I wonder if they
would have made Man of Steel back in
[Music]
1977-78 daughter here before I know like
if I have the technology that tone that
movie can you imagine like that would
have been the world Superman kid your
mom yeah but we were so excited
literally just to see a guy fly that was
the tango Marlene yeah man can fly I'm
the new to do wanna matosinhos you
believe you will cry I point to the fact
that [ __ ] sue Chris Reeve Superman
like killed Zod and non or non went to
fly himself and then fell but [ __ ]
Superman took his powers away and then
Lois Lane killed the other girl like
there's death going on that was their
version of banished it's just there's a
bunch of datacenters fill it
I was shot great I just wanted to see
the family again like did they die like
the neck like snap trajectory I just
don't firing even though that man be
Superman like you killed that family
there's odds head Oh that'd be crazy
yeah man so you've seen most of it now
I've seen some okay I'm happy I would
have seen I can't I can't I just wants
the end to end I just want to see
everything I love I like what I've seen
so far he looks straight out the books
yeah he looks like this he looks perfect
yeah one that suit I'm ready they're
everywhere would you really know as long
as I wear that cowl at Comic Con maybe
30 minutes you can probably we can get
some duct tape and make it cuz this suit
looks like Alfred make me understand
give me some duct tape Alfred we have
been here in the fact cave with a huge
huge obvious huge [ __ ] fan bunch of
people right now are just like holy [ __ ]
I'm getting this album because they
[ __ ] I'd like to cut of your jib
because you liked [ __ ] comics thank
you in advance this is real comics right
here man a fan made [ __ ] good what
did he do with some bona fides once he
got a little juice he immediately went
to the source material the wellspring
that got him where he is today man
creativity imagination of his youth in
comics and he went back and [ __ ] drew
super [ __ ] Batman number 50 you
didn't do that you could write before
they're about to rebirth it or whatever
that is
and right before the Reaper before the
afterburn that's [ __ ] crazy there it
is look at that cover man that's a good
looking book dude I'm serious a pencils
really nice thank you for like those
pencils were really really strong them
they need no [ __ ] believe that I mean
with all due respect you didn't need
thanks Jim now I remember what I was
gonna say when I was saying about why it
was so significant that I had that book
so kapu low mmm he's been doing the run
for a while number 39 or 38 there's a
shot of Batman hang gliding into a bunch
of thugs and there's a sign at a bar and
I didn't even see this when I'd already
read the book some fan posted the panel
and then it was Daltrey's like bar I
think Danny Mickey
Kapoor left it open and Danny put it in
and so on my pencils I'm trying to keep
that place in business but that was on
the background there you'll see it I'm
gonna keep it standing what is it
Dodgers right and uh kept it alive in
continuity and so when he destroyed all
the buildings I said can you at least
like though that sign like in there are
good he's really [ __ ] strong man it's
a good perspective let me inform you
I'll show you the original into salad
thank you okay give it here they punched
in there it is man you can see it it's
right on his fingertips he's holding
your [ __ ] name up keeping that [ __ ]
going the bat was it time to do short
ears or long yours
no I because it was because it's the
baby have a certain artists doing the
movie suits yeah on certain books and
then some doing the 52 so they gave me
the 52 so I was trying to like bridge
that gap because I do like the shorter
ears
mm-hm imagine for the
the longest time I was always like it's
gotta be the longer skies because of the
Neil Adams and Kelly Jones
[Music]
they were just because of practicality
sake but I love that because you look at
the Kelly Jones Batman I got a [ __ ]
again a Batmobile
I need a trigger to ditch something you
need a deck master Bruce fine and that's
how Robin Robin oh there it is folks
[ __ ] thanks for hanging out with us
here the [ __ ] in the fat cakes I could
give it up fake to the man thank you
he's [ __ ] you caught him he bleeds
[ __ ] comics right there actually come
you try to cut him she's pretty strong
show me your guns malfunction yeah sure
playing guitar all the time and I say
you workout I imagine is that your arms
got to be strong enough to like hold it
up and keep moving right your arms
everything for your bag it's like the
weight of the guitars like forces you to
kind of have terrible posture real is
that made my bass player oh he's walking
around like Newton pack break we brought
an inversion table out on the road on
stage he's doing inversion now I can
only take like 30 seconds before my
head's gonna explode strong dude rocking
is hard work man
it is right here honestly I couldn't
think of a better job right yeah
anything that you love you know
listen was my good masseur you say you
do it give a signal to say that say
right to the camera tell them what they
made a job y'all am I looking at this
one that one the one oh you got it then
I already did one
I don't do takes how I wrap on Daughtry
you do what you love to do and you'll
never work a day in your life isn't that
what they say yes yes and you're not
gonna say it's that hard you said these
take credit for Chris Daughtry first one
never say that yeah on the show this one
in Judas choice knows it was coined by
Jews back in the early 2000 AD or so it
was the last thing BC where he went to
the tree do it you love kids you'll
never work continually I traded out the
Savior so I'm gonna
I remember story ending badly it didn't
end good no didn't give I love coins I
remember when I was a kid though he's
like I don't need these cards anymore
that's the mega art of the Bible he was
not her kid you're like holy [ __ ] he was
betrayed down and there's justice too
because he kills himself don't ever [ __ ]
with Jesus like that was a metal part of
that story you've got a metal part dude
mm-hmm
just like a [ __ ] like the dark
side do the dark side you're the Lex
Luthor of the back of the [ __ ] Jesus
earners dars Judas he lost his legs
yeah so I'm the Darth Maul he's y'all
should have more dialogue so wait the
guy on the right is actually
what do you what do you mean that was a
Star Wars day I thought you were their
celebration at Star Wars Celebration
did you dress up yeah went around an
interview and fan so that's [ __ ]
Darth Maul yeah so wait in the guy sorry
part that's G already as he looks like I
do in normal life and I look like it was
the end of the day so I've been
interviewing around the Convention
Center and we're about to leave and we
heard he was over there doing a song I
was like oh this is perfect full circle
we ended like this and that's how we
ended it me talking to him I interviewed
Darth Maul and I was Chris Daughtry
Daltrey is bigger than you that's really
good right now
it's on YouTube so you're sitting there
gone I've never dressed up like Darth
Maul he has so I'm all up your cosplay
if Daughtry has time for cosplay so do
CollegeHumor the first time as and then
we reprised the Kris Darth tree role oh
he's so you direct your own show no I
mean that single why it's Dutch - or -
it's part of the fat man drinking game
at this point it's true drinking game
you mean well you know home yeah every
time Kevin tells them to change the
camera drink me drunk by the second
shots so your last shot is the floor man
the set the last shots in the glass the
martini everybody that's movie talk
right there we talk can't think of a
better way in the show than on movie
talk but only movie people understand
the [ __ ] hang there he is man the you
watch the most recent episode from flash
yeah so you know who zoom is yeah
because he saw the dude on the bench
where I didn't that'd be away like
remember how her so maybe he was I'm
here yes I'm saying so he was hunter
zolomon the whole time pretending BJ
because that dude is Jay who do you
think is the man in the iron mask I have
no clue oh maybe that's Jay but how many
Jay you say I will since a lot of them
there's a lot of hurts I won't say that
that I was thinking it could have been
Diggle for a second because the helmet
no he act looked like he had a black
man's hands oh the guy banging on the
window
yeah like it look like
on the screenshot but he's looking a
little skinny to be size of a house
we'll be like look if I'm gonna wear a
helmet again can you put a better helmet
on me the reason I say that is because
Jay is pretty pale so I don't know he
wasn't so scary anymore
[Music]
I was kind of like that would be nice
there was a [ __ ] mad the same way
I'll walk down Hamilton as I head up my
game use up my game man and see that
goddamn it
that's what happens when you hang out
fat man Batman folks fun things like
that
Chris Daughtry's when I guess amazing
[ __ ] man yes he's geeky as you if not
[ __ ] geek here and [ __ ] you saw him
dressed up like Darth Maul you see my
Batman might stand on the road like well
it was on the road and then I retired it
and it's the studio what and what was it
it's just a big bass is just a huge bit
I think I've said sent really picture
tape so watch this now in the studio
Mike you can sit there I have the studio
I think the same dude that made like
Tommy Lee's drum cage made him really
yeah it's in there it's like a long shot
yes is directing the show as well tell
him to go to slide like we're in the
walk do you see you did you not find it
cool if you don't find it but your looks
wrong in my snaps we're way off
we have no rhythm whatsoever it is
embarrassing information I'm saying you
know what I just pretended I didn't see
it we're saying for the two of them all
right that's it go to the three shot we
got in the walking show yeah I'll show
you later he's got a mic stamp yeah I
got my ass battle at no bigs
there it is folks for fat man I'm Batman
Kevin Smith Mark Barnard and this guy's
Chris Chris don't come back to the fat
cave next episode saying that I'm saved
that Channel
well you do backups nice Kevin Smith I
almost forgot it for a second bad place
a man's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder